Let's talk about Iowa.
We still, as of this recording, don't have
final results from the Iowa caucus, the first
in the nation primary, which took place on
Monday night.
It is time now to just very clearly say with
no ifs, ands and buts.
No caveats, no restrictions whatsoever.
Iowa can't get the privilege of being the
first to vote in primary elections anymore,
period.
Full stop.
Now, there are a whole bunch of reasons for
this and most of the reasons why Iowa actually
shouldn't be the first to vote, have nothing
to do with the fiasco from Monday night.
The benefit of the fiasco from Monday night,
if there is one, if there is a silver lining,
is that it's a good opportunity to put back
in the spotlight that Iowa should not get
the privilege of being first to vote.
It's nothing personal against Iowa or Iowa.
Iowans are perfectly nice people, uh, the,
the ones that I've met, but this is a much
bigger problem that we are dealing with here.
First and foremost, Iowa is not remotely representative
of the democratic electorate nor of the country's
demographics in any way.
There's just no factual reason.
There's no empirical case for Iowa getting
to be the first to vote when it comes to race
and ethnicity.
It's very obvious.
Iowa and New Hampshire, the first two to vote
are 90% white.
The country is 60% white when it comes to
economics.
When it comes to education, there is no mathematical
or empirical justification for Iowa being
the place where it makes sense to start and
going first does carry disproportionate influence
over the eventual subsequent primaries.
There's a good Vox piece from a couple of
days ago which reminds us that there was a
37 point swing in the national polls when
John Kerry won in Iowa and New Hampshire 16
years ago in the 2004 democratic primary.
Now then we get to the disaster on Monday
night, the fiasco Monday night with the app
crashing and the results being delayed and
immediate foul play and conspiracy theories
exploding.
It doesn't help Iowa's case and it is another
reason for realistically not even having a
single state be the first to vote, but instead
having a number of States being the first
to vote.
You could organize this any number of different
ways.
You could say, well, we will divide the country
into regions.
We'll have the Northeast and the Southeast
and we'll have the West coast, whatever, and
we will have one state from each region vote
first on the first primary day.
Or we could say if we really are convinced
that we want to have one state go first and
one state only, which I don't think makes
sense, you could at least rotate the state
or you could pick a different state that is
more Def demographically representative of
the country.
Like for example, Illinois is often mentioned
because of its racial and ethnic and educational
breakdown, uh, as compared to the country
at large, it would be a much better fit.
You could use similar metrics, other good
options for which States should go first.
If we're trying to have a state that's representative
of the country, you can look at New Jersey,
you could look at New York, you could look
at Florida.
It doesn't have to be a blue state.
Remember, it's the democratic primary that
we're talking about and this is also a good
time to mention that there is nothing in the
constitution about how primaries are supposed
to be run.
A lot of people don't realize that the democratic
and the Republican parties, these are not
government entities and primaries are not
real elections in a sense.
In a sense they are, but in a sense they are
not.
And what I mean by that is that the process
and the rules and the parameters for these
primaries are decided on by the parties and
the members of the parties.
And of course at the state level.
And we're going to get to that cause that
is a factor.
Back in 2016 you could tell a lot of people
didn't realize that parties decide how to
run the primaries because people were looking
at what the DNC did in terms of how they structured
the debates and how they helped Hillary Clinton
as maybe being illegal was not illegal.
This was not a legal issue.
What the DNC did in 2016.
Now you do have state law and state constitutions
that make this more complicated.
You have a, for example, uh, lots of States
have laws about when the primary is supposed
to happen.
Iowa says that it's caucus must happen eight
days before any other state's proceedings.
That's why New Hampshire is eight days after
Iowa's caucus.
New Hampshire has a law that says they must
be the first primary, which is why Iowa goes
first, but it's a caucus and not a primary,
so I don't want to pretend that getting States
to change their laws about this is easy.
It's difficult for sure, but the DNC can push
them if they want to.
It's not clear that the DNC wants to change
the system that we have so much like the electoral
college.
More broadly, we are dealing with what are
effectively outdated and broken systems at
this point.
Even the delegate system needs to be, you
could do a national vote in the entire country
on the same day with instant runoff voting
at the state level, giving everybody more
equal say and equal influence regardless of
where it is that they live.
My preference would be to come up with a way
to have more States go first, if not all,
or to rotate who gets to go first?
Why would it be bad for Connecticut Democrats
or Washington state Democrats to go first
every once in a while?
It wouldn't be unless you want to perpetuate
the DNCs stranglehold, an influence over the
way that this is run.
That being said, this will not solve if you
have a different state, go first.
That state still has disproportionate power
and influence and makes a bigger impact and
that is ultimately something that the DNC
wants because it makes the primary easier
to control.
Uh, also just as a, as a Coda, the first primary
shouldn't be a caucus and in fact, I would
support getting rid of caucuses altogether,
period.
And any process that involves coin flips and
requires hours of participation is outdated.
I won't call it bad, it's just not realistically
fine tuned and a good process in 2020 change
my mind.
I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman.
Follow me there.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this